question 14 here so it's just beneath
here in the textbook it says by
expanding the brackets find and then you
have these various integrals down here
and the reason why I thought it's worth
doing one of these examples with you is
not because it's different in essence to
your other questions but because it
comes up so frequently is something
which students find difficult so let's
write down the question first I'm
looking at Part C right on the end there
it's 2 root X take away 1 squared and
that's what I'm integrating with respect
to X now when you have a look at this
you might be tempted to think oh this is
one of those questions where I can
choose should I expand or should I use
reverse chain rule but it's not um is a
reason why the question has encouraged
you to expand why is it a bad idea to
try and use the reverse chain rule on
this well let's just go back to how I
had a look at questions 6f right I had a
look at this guy and I said look at the
integrand I'm just to remind you the
integrand is this guy here well Wow and
I get that that's not helpful let's do
this the old-fashioned way this is the
integrand here right 2x plus 1 all
squared and I said that thing being
squared 2x plus 1 what's the inside
derivative there it's two it's just a
constant right and that's why I can use
your first chain rule we're good to go
when you have a look here though you've
got something quite different what's the
inside function here if this is your
integrand then your inside function
that's being squared that was a terrible
curly brace let's try it again is 2 root
X minus 1 that's your f of X now if
that's f of X equals what would F dash
be well hopefully it's not clicking for
you this is not just going to be a
constant is it 2 root X is 2x to the
power of 1/2 so if I were to
differentiate that I would have the half
comes down and then I reduce the power
by 1 now that's not just a constant is
it that's actually what's going to
happen here cancel cancel 1 on root X so
you can't just multiply or divide by
over rude acts to make it nice and neat
it's not a constant coefficient so
that's why the way to go with this is
definitely to expand now in this case
I'm actually not going to even finish
the question for you I'm just going to
help you out with the expansion and then
you can finish out the question yourself
let's have a go here we're going to
square the first term entirely now be
careful be really really careful I
wonder if you can guess what the most
common error here is what would students
do as they try to square and expand this
out I can tell you right now even
without seeing students do this they'd
like 50% of the time you're going to
write 2x because they're on autopilot
trying to think of getting rid of that
square root sign so they're like I
squared the X done but you can't just
square the X you have to square the
entire term so since it's 2 root X what
you're really going to get is 2 squared
X which I guess is 4 X so now squared
that s where the second term and then
I'm going to do double the product of
both of them so the product of both is
minus 2 root X so double that will be
minus 4 root X again I haven't actually
done any integration at this point I've
just expanded but I'm still not ready
yet at least in my brain to integrate
this I'm going to do one more thing so I
still have my integral sign there
therefore X looks good the plus one
looks good but that 4 root X I want it
hopefully you're getting a sense of this
now I wanted an index form so I can use
but the rules that I know so I'm gonna
write this is 4 X ^ whoopsie-daisy 1/2
now I'm ready to integrate and hopefully
you are too so I'm gonna leave that one
sitting there for you guys to have a go
out and finish when you're doing the
other questions in this exercise okay
all right now the last worked example
that we're going to do before we close
things up and it's a good idea because
we're looking at the time is all the way
in question 20 I'm skipping a lot of
questions because there's a bunch of
definite integrals here that we've
already addressed so 20 Part C is a two
parter part one looks like this find the
derivative of this term here so we've
got here or this expression I should say
X to the 5 minus 7 to the power of a and
then we'll see how we can use it to
bus with part-2 so let's have a go
we're just differentiating so
derivatives decrease powers right so I'm
going to deal with the inside then I'll
deal with the outside the inside
derivative will be 5 X to the 4 that
negative 7 different shirts to 0
there's my inside derivative and I'll
multiply that by my outside derivative
so index comes out the front and then I
reduce the index by 1 there we go
teeny bit of tidying up that can happen
there the 5 times the a that gives me 40
X to the 4 and then the rest is hanging
out there I am definitely not going to
try and expand that because that would
take me a long time for some wood sets
so I'm done there's part 1 what's part 2
asking us well if you just sort of scan
along it says hence and hopefully
remember this language from the exam
review that we did hence means I have to
use the part that we just had a look at
I'm going to use that knowledge
hence integrate 40 X to the 4 my arm
times X to the 5 etc so I'm integrating
this guy here the which is the answer I
got from the previous question like so
now being that this is identical right
this thing here is exactly equivalent to
this thing up here then integrating is
just going to take me back to that
primitive function where I began right
it's going to be X to the 5 take away 7
to the power a just with one difference
because of course that's not the only
function which differentiates to give
this result I could have had X to the 5
minus 7 to the power of 8 plus 1 or
minus 8 or anything like that so I have
my constant of integration to look after
that now just as a side note because
other questions in that set will do this
if I were integrating something slightly
different suppose I were integrating 20
X to the 4 X to the 5 minus 7 to the
power 7 now this guy is not exactly
equal it's half the science right so you
can do two things to compensate for this
you could say well I want there to be a
40 there I want there to be 40 X to the
4 and all the rest
that's what I got from the previous
question but you can't just make it 40
because you want to I have to make sure
that the next line is equal so I'm going
to write a half at the front to say 1/2
times 40 is still equal to xx haven't
actually changed things just written it
in a different form so now I can say
that's 1/2 times X to the 5 minus 7 all
^ 8 that's plus my constant so that's
one way of doing it well you could think
to yourself oh this is just half the
size of what I have before so my
integral will also be half the size
whatever you'll get the same result with
that coefficient